I have to be honest I'm so excited and
ready to marry Brian former Bachelorette
Rachel Lindsey and Brian Abba solo have
tied the knot Rachel got engaged to
Brian on her season finale of The
Bachelorette in 2017
[Applause]
[Music]
on Thursday Brian share to pick up the
pair in the back of a car headed off for
a quote adventure both wearing white
seemingly on their way to the big day
I'm gonna get a bridezilla out of you oh
never never no no no earlier this year
Rachel shared details about their
nuptials with et it will be a
destination wedding in a warmer location
closer to Colombia where Brian's from
but it's not in Colombia and I'm excited
as you can see I did not go the
traditional route so I am doing things a
little different than I thought so I'm
excited
I wanted a 50-person wedding we're
already at 150 she also revealed her
plans to walk down the aisle and address
the paid homage to their Bachelorette
past I'm gonna go with Randi ROM she did
the dress that I met the guys in the
first night she designed the dress that
Brian proposed to me in so it only makes
sense that that's who I go with to
design my wedding dress that I'm walking
down the aisle to Brian congratulations
to the happy couple
[Music]